مصدر ثالث للبروتين اضيف للقوائم المعروفه
هو سولين بروتين ينتج من بكتيريا التربه
تعتمد اليه انتاج هذا الصنف البروتينيه
الجديده على تغذيه بكتيريا يطلق عليها
بكتيريا التربه للثاني اكسيد الكربون
وبالهيدروجين بعد فصله عن الماء بواسطه
الكهرباء تقوم تلك الاحياء الدقيقه بعمليه
التخمير المناسبه بعد اعطائها مغذيات
معدنيه لتصبح قادره على تكوين الاحماض
الامينيه والكربوهيدرات والدهون
والفيتامينات يقوم العلماء بعد ذلك بازاله
اي رطوبه زائده ويكون الناتج الاخير مسحوق
جافا غنيا بالبروتين بنسبه تصل حتى 65%
يمكن اضافه المسحوق لاي نوع من الطعام
والوجبات اما النكهه فلا شيء وهو ما يريده
الباحثون اي حياديه سولين مع جميع انواع
الطعام طورت هذه التقنيه شركه في الانديه
اسمها سولار فودز وهي تعمل على جمع
التمويل اللازم لمضاعفه كميات الانتاج
يقول باحث سولار فودز ان هذه التقنيه
الزراعيه الجديده لا تنتج اي غازات دفيئه
وتوفر الكثير من استهلاك المياه كما يمكن
ان يكون سولين على فن الماشيه بديله من
فول الصويا الذي يزرع على حساب ازاله
الغابات المطيره
فانها ستصبح اقل 11 مرات من كلفه انتاج
البروتين الحيواني بحلول عام 35 يلخص
علماء قيمه هذا الاكتشاف بالقول انه سيتيح
لنا اطعام العالم العالم دون ان نلتهم
العالم